blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
davidpackman so for some strange reason
Republicans cannot seem to get away from
proposing quack cures and treatments and
preventions for covid that are actually
nothing of the sort and our latest
participant is Republican Senator Ron
Johnson this is a sitting Senator this
is someone in the U.S Senate the
greatest what do they call it the
greatest deliberative body in the United
States in the world who knows
um he is saying gargle with mouthwash
and even mouthwash companies are saying
gargle with mouthwash if you want but it
doesn't do anything as far as covid is
concerned and this took place during a
recent teletown Hall that he did on
Wednesday and he said it's been proven
that mouthwash uh can kill the
coronavirus and as usual the devil is
sort of in the details they often start
with a grain of a kernel of a seed of
something that has some connection to
reality they expand it and of course in
the background is the idea that they say
and because these things exist you don't
really need to go and get vaccinated so
let's take a look at the clip listen to
it then we'll talk about it but there
are things you can do again vitamin D
you know zinc keep yourself healthy uh
vitamin C by the way uh standard Garba
a mouthwash that has been proven to kill
the coronavirus even if you get it if
you you know you may reduce viral
replication there's all you know why not
try all these things
um it just boggles my mind that the NIH
continues to tell people do nothing you
know maybe take Tylenol so notice by the
way that not only does Ron Johnson
mention mouthwash there he mentions
vitamin D he mentions zinc and he
mentions vitamin C so we're gonna we're
gonna look at each of these one by one
um they they start with like a grain of
Truth a kernel of Truth and so what that
could be here is that if you take a
petri dish and you put in viral droplets
of coronavirus and you pour mouthwash on
them
um often mouthwash with high alcohol
content
does it quote kill the virus it almost
certainly happens and that can happen
when you pour a whole bunch of different
things in a Petri dish onto viral
droplets the problem is that when you
have the virus it's in your breathing
system it's in the nasal area it's in
the lungs Etc so in some very literal
sense
mouthwash kills the virus when you
gargle okay and this goes back to Lysol
does too and you inject bleach and all
this stuff just because on some
fundamental level with direct exposure
it kills the virus you're not preventing
infection from the virus if it's in your
body
um you gargle you maybe kill whatever is
in your mouth maybe and then you breathe
and then there's more and it's in your
nasal cavity etc etc and Listerine
actually put out a statement saying
Listerine does not prevent covid
Listerine does not treat covid do not
use it thinking that it would do
anything at all period Then Ron Johnson
mentions the vitamin D and the zinc and
the vitamin C so let's talk about those
because those have also been studied and
again there's nothing here it's we have
something that works and it's the
vaccine and against earlier variants it
was very good at preventing infection
and hospitalization and death against
the newer Omicron variant if you only
have two doses it's less good at
preventing infection three seems to be
better still very good at preventing
serious illness and death big picture
statistically is what we know right now
so let's go through his list you've got
vitamin D vitamin D is something that
has been looked at extensively from the
beginning it's an important thing to
look at uh there is an association
between higher vitamin D
and generally speaking less serious or
less coveted
in general having a good vitamin D level
which now is considered to be above 30 I
forget what it is micrograms per Pico
liter or you know whatever whatever the
measurement is over 30 and that's just
generally good for fighting things off
it's not clear there's anything specific
to covet about vitamin D it's not clear
that taking a vitamin D supplement helps
prevent cobit and in fact when they look
at people hospitalized with covid and
check vitamin D levels and they say on
average they're lower it's not even
clear whether that's causation
correlation or reverse causation meaning
are you in the hospital because you had
a lower vitamin D level or did having a
serious case of covet lower the vitamin
D level that's another question that is
that is being asked so generally
speaking is it good to have a a an above
30 vitamin D level yes is it good
specifically because of covet no it's
just a general thing
um zinc zinc and vitamin D have been
studied oh sorry vitamin C there are a
ton a ton a ton of uh trials on this and
one very good one did four groups you
had a group that received only the
standard of Care at the time for coven
remember you don't compare it to nothing
you compare any intervention to what is
the standard at this point in time you
had group one with the standard of Care
Group Two got zinc group three got
vitamin C and group four got zinc and
vitamin C in the form of ascorbic acid
um no difference no difference and the
there there was
214 patients with confirmed covid
receiving Outpatient Care no difference
in how long the symptoms last or the
likelihood of ending up hospitalized
that's one study and there's many others
so all of this goes to what
it goes to he's recommending all sorts
of different things including things
that are within the medical realm but
have been studied and don't seem to
actually change outcomes things like
gargling with mouthwash which is close
to the inject bleach I mean it's the
same concept right it's the mouthwatch
kills it when we know we have something
that works as and is FDA approved fully
that's the Pfizer vaccine uh we have via
emergency use authorization the
monoclonal antibodies which are better
than Placebo but it's still no Panacea
as as we learned but that's not what
he's talking about instead he's talking
about all of these other things it's not
only ignorant it's also dangerous
because a lot of people hear it and they
go look at all these treatments we have
if you look at them one by one you see
these really aren't actually treatments
for covet earlier this week I mentioned
to you
that Joe Biden has almost completely
ended the Drone war and it has barely
made a headline and we talked about some
of the reasons why that is on the Monday
show a Joe Biden has also overseen I'm
not saying caused under notice the
language I'm using Joe Biden is also
overseen
some of the fastest economic recovery in
American history by the metrics that
Republicans love to use and that's also
barely being discussed there's a really
good article in the hill by our friend
Max Burns who outlines this and again
it's by the standards used to judge the
economy what's happening is quite
notable the economy is now close to Full
Employment unemployment down from 6.7 a
year ago to 4.2
in the past similar declines have taken
three years rather than one labor force
participation you know a favorite of
Republicans is at its highest level
since the pandemic wages are up in many
Industries GDP growth is taking place
and somehow there is still significant
pessimism about the economy now of
course on right-wing media there's
pessimism about the economy but also
among Americans who were just surveyed
polled and asked what's your general
feeling about the economy now does this
mean there isn't suffering of course
there is suffering does this mean we
don't have the same systemic economic
issues about fairness wages overall
inequality health insurance we we have
all of those different things but by
their standards what's happening is
quite stunning remember they talk about
unemployment rate labor force
participation
stock market as well and stock market
has been doing very very well they also
when it's a republican in the White
House say that when there's good
economic indicators it's thanks to the
president that is in the white house
with Joe Biden I'm not even saying that
I I you don't even have to it's by their
standard you attribute these things to
the man or woman historically it's been
a man who is in the white house now is
inflation increasingly an issue it is we
talked about it yesterday with
Congressman rokana it's an issue
um it also is fair to say that any
particular individual's well-being is
not
totally coupled to these broader
economic indicators and that's true no
matter who is president note that I'm
stepping back from is it a democrat or a
republican the point here is not to say
Biden's a hero and fixed everything in
fact he fixed nothing yet about the
systemic economic issues that we Face
the other reason for pessimism is that
to be honest there's some ignorance
about what a good economy even means I
mean for many people
they might have a job
and be doing fine but they are aware
that prices are going up so when the
poll asks them are you pessimistic or
optimistic about the economy they go I'm
pessimistic even though the inflation is
not affecting them and it's not going to
okay well uh if you can afford
everything and you're doing fine is the
economy doing poorly or not depends on
what the scope of the question is are
you saying for me systemically what are
you actually saying seventy percent of
the people pulled said they are doing
fine but still feel the economy is not
good if it's fine for 70 percent how bad
is it and this isn't to minimize the
experience of those who are not doing
well the point here is you've got by the
standards they choose things looking
pretty good and there are also these
kind of polling artifacts and
incongruities that don't necessarily
prove or disprove the economy's good or
the economy is bad but it makes us
wonder when people are even asked these
questions
what is making them say one thing versus
another and often when you look into it
you know the right loves to make out a
big make a big deal out of you can't
trust polling when you're simply asking
who are you going to vote for in fact
generally speaking well-sampled polls
which just say who are you going to vote
for are mostly trustworthy generally
speaking within the margin of error
um the the polls that I think really we
have to look at with more skepticism are
these opinion polls about what is your
sense of how this or that is going
because often people will answer one way
you ask them two or three questions and
their actual nitty-gritty opinion would
suggest they should have answered the
complete opposite way so interesting
numbers but in particular interesting
that these are metrics where if it was a
republican in the White House they would
be saying this is unbelievable and it's
thanks to the Republican in the White
House in this case it's Biden they're
certainly not attributing any of it to
Biden and they're not even really
acknowledging that the numbers look
pretty good send me your thoughts let me
know why and what you think is
underlying this you can find me on
Twitter at the Pacman and remember that
next Tuesday the 14th 6 PM Eastern we'll
be doing our next viewer Town Hall it'll
be live on the Pac-Man Live YouTube
channel hope you'll join me then
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the David packman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app I just
listened to this is your mind on Plants
by the great Michael pollen super
interesting the history of caffeine and
so many other things blinkist has you
covered on podcast two blinkist takes
long episodes of popular podcasts and
distills them into audio you can listen
to and 15 minutes with blinkist you can
become knowledgeable about so many
different things you can have
conversations with people about more
topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blink is for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
davidpakman the link is down below
the David Pacman show does count on
great people like you signing up for
memberships on our website at
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
day called the bonus show for our
members you also get a commercial free
audio and video feed of the show if you
like as well as other great member
benefits sign up at joinpakman.com
coupon code available but not mandatory
is better 21. let's hear from some
people in the audience if you'd like to
chat with me you can go to
davidpackman.com Discord we use the
Discord for calls and that is a great
great thing let's start today with Felix
from Maryland Felix you're on the air
what's going on
hi there uh not too much are you I'm
doing well thank you
cool uh I wanted to ask you excuse me
I'm a little sick uh do you think that
this day we're in the middle of a
political realignment
oh well tell me more political
realignment of what kind
you know I don't know I've so I've just
kind of like been watching politics from
like afar for a while and I I feel like
um I just feel like a lot has changed
and like that like since uh I really
started paying attention more back in
like 2008 when Obama ran I feel like a
lot has changed mainly from like the
culture war and I felt like a lot of
like culture and social issues were
um making people who are sort of
apolitical or
um not really uh you know super focused
on politics uh it would help them come
more to the left
um because a lot of people I felt like
were turned off because the right was
more like a Family Values social
conservative type of party yeah I feel
like that's changed a lot and you know
the right and the Republicans are like
now like they've completely abandoned
especially with after Trump they've
abandoned the whole like
um you know family judeo-christian
values aesthetic and stuff and now I I
just I weirdly see that the culture war
is starting to like benefit them
well I I so let's see you're absolutely
right about some of these particulars
that you're noticing
um I don't think it's a realignment in
the sense of Republicans and Democrats
are switching and what it means to be in
one party versus the other I don't think
that that's changing I think the
realignment that we're seeing is that it
started under Obama and it exploded
under Trump and it's continuing now
Republicans are no longer even
pretending to be about policy they are
as you pointed out they're about
cultural issues they're about owning the
libs they're about trying to win
elections by deciding which ballots do
and don't count they're not really
making substantive and meaningful
political cases to their voters saying
here are the things we will do and
here's why it will help you they'll
still vaguely say the Democrats are
crushing us with debt or they're
crushing us with taxes or whatever but
that that's like that's not that doesn't
count as policy in my mind you're not
really substantive proposing
Alternatives and solutions other than
we'll cut taxes and we'll you know pay
down the debt which they don't ever do
um but I think that the realignment is
that they used to at least pretend to be
about policy they don't even pretend to
be about policy anymore
you know
um yeah I think that's true to an extent
uh I I I definitely feel like yeah they
used to pretend to be about policy and
like on the like cultural issues they
they used to be all about like upholding
you know family values and stuff like
that like I was saying yeah but
I feel like I feel like now
I I don't know I just feel like I'm
seeing like more a little bit more like
diversity in thinking of some people who
would like vote right wing and the fact
that like a lot of them seem to even
like support drug legalization a lot of
them have kind of like come to terms
with letting you know allowing uh uh
same-sex marriage and things like that
right and uh no that's a good point I'm
curious I'm curious like where where
this is going because even like in a few
years from now like what what are they
uh what what are the what's the party
going to look like and what is their
vote what are their vase and their
voters going to look like if if this
continues I feel like they could win
over a lot of uh people on some of those
issues that right yeah I mean what
you're what you're pointing to is that
there were a bunch of people who before
Trump were never politically engaged or
motivated at all and what Trump was able
to do was find people who never paid
attention to politics and basically say
here are your values use and vote for me
and I'm a republican so Trump did to his
credit bring in people who believe
themselves to be for example against
military interventions around the world
because Trump claimed to be against that
but Trump's not really against that it
was just a way that he was able to
criticize George W bush
um you're right that they don't seem to
be homophobic uh some of these folks at
least not outwardly so because Donald
Trump did not make that a big part of
his campaign I think you're absolutely
right but I think the bigger question is
do those people really stay engaged in
politics after Trump is gone and we
don't know the answer to that yet they
may or they may bail
okay yeah well it's just been really
interesting it's just all the time I say
these days if I could like go back in
time and tell myself like this would be
the environment would look like 10 years
from now it that would be shocked yes it
would anyway I appreciate it you have a
good day thank you have a good one all
right there we go there's uh there
there's Felix let's go um so many
different folks wanting to chat today
let's go next to Glenn from Virginia
Glenn you're on the air
hi David can you hear me I can hear you
just fine
okay great this is my first time calling
thanks for taking the call Pleasure uh
my my question for you is with respect
to voting uh rights uh just to give you
context I am an African-American in my
mid-40s
and I fear that uh there will likely be
no meaningful voting rights legislation
uh coming down the pipeline so my
question for you is do you think the
Democrats
mischaracterized well let me rephrase
instead of saying mischaracterized do
you think that they did a poor job in
messaging as you know so much with
respect to legislation comes down to
messaging and what I mean by that is uh
with voting rights legislation do you
think the Democrats would have done
themselves uh more of a service if they
sold it as an issue for the less
powerful the less connected uh those who
are in perhaps uh rural areas and having
access to voting as opposed to selling
it more of a race issue with respect to
black and brown people do you think the
Democrats sort of fumbled the football
so to speak in that regard it's always
hard to go back and say what what might
have been but it's a good question which
is if the framing along uh defending
voting rights and pushing back against
all of these wacky right-wing bills had
been they are going after the little guy
rather than they are targeting
disproportionately non-white minorities
would it have been better received
here's the thing
for the people on the left who
understand the issue they're already
behind supporting voting rights in a
real way and fighting back against what
Republicans are doing and if the left
had framed it in the way you suggest the
right is still going to be just as
against it and they would come up with
some way to justify it and so then it
just becomes a fight of like do they do
it effectively or not I I just don't
know they're sometimes one of the prop
one of the mistakes we make is we say
hey you know what here's the talking
point they came up with and that talking
point was so easily defeated here's a
different talking point that would have
been much better but what you have to
remember is if the talking point had
been different their response also would
have been different and so I just don't
know because fundamentally Republican
elected officials know that they need
all of these different voter suppression
tactics in order to win and they were
going to justify them one way or the
other so it's it's hard for me to say
that it would have been much more
successfully uh argued if they argued
along class rather than race lines and
to be honest they did also argue it
along class lines because often it's
about poor areas not non-white areas
yeah I I agree uh I just look back at
some of the tactics of uh you know the
Obama Administration especially uh in
the 2012 campaign they sort of
anticipated the backlash so to speak and
they were much more Nimble in making the
class Warfare argument and even if the
Republican attempts are based on uh
racial uh sensitivities I just think you
do yourself a lot more of a service if
you make the class Warfare argument yeah
I'm not disagreeing with you my only
caveat would be I think the Republican
Party would have been ready for that as
well but I don't think you're wrong
okay fair enough thanks for trying to
call all right thanks Glenn there is
Glenn a very very important topic I mean
a great uh great great uh question to be
asking let's go next to Joseph from
Tucson Joseph you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes I can
hi um I just had a question
where given the amount of just totally
unprecedented events that we've seen
over the past couple of years yeah would
it even be very accurate to use
assessments from precedent when thinking
about something like the midterms in
2022 I think uh you you're making a good
point which is we make all of these
historical analyzes uh typically after
you know it's sort of like in in
baseball where they say you know um the
uh the Orioles in the seventh and eighth
innings in Day games played after
September
they tend to hit 400 with runners in
scoring position and it's like okay does
that historical analysis really tell us
anything actionable or substantive about
today and things are so wacky and
different right now we have a question
mark around like all those trumpists
that were activated by Trump do they
care about the midterms are they going
to vote all of these different things so
I think it's fair to ask the question I
still do think that things are lining up
very much as they have historically
which is Democrats took the White House
in 2020. it's not looking good for
Democrats in the House of
Representatives in 2022 I think a lot of
those historical things are are
plausible in terms of the next election
cycle or two but you're right that we
always have to say well what's different
this time it might not all be the same
all right well very interesting thanks
for taking my call my pleasure uh great
to hear from you there uh there's Joseph
from Tucson
why don't we go next
to Tobias from Germany Tobias from
Germany you're on here
thanks for having me my pleasure yes I
can
ah great
uh I have two questions the first one is
that mainly your opinion about freedom
of speech because when I look at the
complete situation I think that the
media has a big part of the city of the
situations that you are in now so lies
on Fox the lies from donut
um
it doesn't stop if you thought it might
become better when Biden wins and now
Biden is president for a year but
nothing changed uh they double down and
I don't see anything regarding healing
of society
it's a society gets split more and more
and
do you see any way out of it well
unfortunately
um if anybody thought Joe Biden being
president would reduce the lies in Media
I expected the lies to go up and of
course they have and that's exactly the
way that that I expected it to go but we
don't you know here's the thing we
fundamentally don't have a system that
encourages or favors healing in the way
that you're talking about because it
requires number one putting partisanship
aside and I mean I'm partisan in saying
this but to heal we would need everybody
to say hey you know what that Trump
experiment that was a disaster we can
never do that again we were globally
humiliated under trumpet we we just we
just can't but like that's my partisan
View and someone else would say no no no
David you're you're just wrong about
that that's not what the healing is
going to come from so we can't even get
agreement as to what would cause the
healing to take place so there's a
couple different Topics in there that
you mentioned they're all good but
unfortunately everything is exactly as I
expected the media lives have escalated
with Joe Biden the partisanship is
certainly not diminishing and even
uncontroversial things that Joe Biden
wants to do like an infrastructure plan
are now being seen by the right as these
radical communist ideas which of course
they're not
oh yes
yeah so problem is and I don't see any
way out of it again so the next
elections might be the last well I mean
I don't that that's that's very dark the
next elections might be the last but I
share your concern about growing
authoritarianism for sure I'm I'm right
there with you Tobias
okay
um the answer question if I get time for
it sure
it might be a bit polemic but it's about
the line between being bad in your job
being a bad president not doing your
duty and treason
but what I mean in specific is Donald
loves to have people being upset that
helps them
and he saw a chance in using Corona to
get people upset so he politicizes
Corona
which leads to many dead people instead
of helping American people he is killing
them for his
yeah for his own good
and
isn't there somewhere a line where it's
going to treason yeah there is a line I
don't know what the line is but I think
it's important to mention Trump's
handling of coronavirus even if he
thought it would be good for him it
wasn't good leaders that handled the
pandemic well got re-elected Trump lost
and I believe that if Trump had handled
the pandemic well he would have won so
the one area I disagree with you is I
think Trump may have calculated
pretending there's no pandemic is going
to help me it backfired and it might be
responsible for why he lost
they are good but people are dead I know
I know it doesn't help the people who
died no there's no question but but from
from the political argument you were
making uh Tobias thank you great to hear
from you I really appreciate it
thank you all right there is Tobias from
Germany we're going to take a very quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because we're going right back to the
phones in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right let's hear from a few more
people we take calls via the David
Pacman show Discord which you can find
at davidpackman.com Discord let's go to
David from New York David from New York
you're on the air
hi David yes thanks for taking the
question pleasure um
just off of the bat I wanted to ask your
opinion on
Mayor de Blasio and his
ending of ending of his term and I
believe Eric Adams is going to be the
next mayor of New York City um I want to
ask you your opinions on it I mean I I
don't have any particular hot take uh
you know the the issue that exists
perennially with the New York city mayor
is that as a mayorship it's a very
powerful position being mayor of New
York carries with it Prestige that being
mayor of you know fill in the blank town
in wherever State doesn't
um and the other reality is that no
matter what you do you will have a huge
portion of New York City residents
furious with you no matter what you do
with extremely rare exceptions Giuliani
after 9 11 they were extenuating
circumstances he had a high approval
okay so did George W bush right I mean
and then that was squandered but in New
York City you have first of all such
political differences from Brooklyn to
Staten Island and then of course a mix
in Manhattan and a mix in Queens and you
know Bronx is more left fine politically
it's dramatically different you
basically have the full political gamut
in the city of New York you have
financially dramatically different
circumstances and as a result of that
the Paul policies of one mayor are never
going to satisfy people across a class
and and economic lines
um it is a job where you you are going
to have a huge portion of the city
furious with you and based on that you
know on Eric Adams specifically I don't
really have any predictions or hot takes
okay
um thank you for taking my class I mean
what are you expecting
ah I mean
from the rhetoric that I've heard yeah
that we're looking at a Bloomberg light
version with Eric Eric Adams
um and personally I don't have so much
of a problem with that regarding
um more of a
I would I would personally say an
objective uh
take on policy regarding companies in
New York housing
um
weaning away from a hard right stance
and leaning further away from an
authoritarian stance at Bloomberg uh
took with things such as the soda ban
and other very very unpopular policies
that he was putting out there for simply
uh what looked like
uh ratings kicks yeah I mean I think
you're I don't think Eric Adams is going
to be an authoritarian I don't think
Eric Adams is going to be hard right
he's also not the epitome of the
progressive left I mean I I I my
expectation is that it'll be a
relatively unremarkable mayorship
that or it could be a remarkably good
mayorship oh maybe sure that's more
optimistic
yeah we could be we could look at things
optimistically and noting all those
things that you just did we could be
looking at something that could be
starkly different from anything that
we've experienced so I mean the thing is
I think a lot of that is just going to
ride on the broader economy because New
York a city is such an economically
important Hub of the United States and
Global the global economy a lot of what
determines whether people think Adams is
doing well or not is going to be the
result of economic factors that have
nothing to do with them
yeah that or or
um on the on the other uh on the other
end of the spectrum negatively because
we are still looking at a a hemorrhaging
city
um that no amount of policy could
possibly fix it and I mean I didn't want
to talk about anything uh policy
specific but it now has just come out
that Bill de Blasio has just announced
his most unpopular policy and that's the
vaccine mandate for private businesses
coming into it yeah and let's not even
get into that because I did do a segment
on it and and so I've covered that
extensively but yeah I I and I don't
know if that's going to be upheld but
we'll we'll see but listen let's see
what happens I'm curious as you are to
see what happens in New York City
yeah thank you thank you again for uh
taking my question it was great talking
to you likewise there's David from New
York very much appreciate hearing from
you
um let's keep talking to people because
there there are so many let's go next to
jate from Tallahassee that's not Jake
but Jake with a t that's it that's
interesting
uh yes or kind of like
Nate but with a J there's another way to
put it that's actually much more clear I
think that that's even I would I will
say it that way for now what's on your
mind Jade
um I wanted to ask you about
the
uh in Florida I'm seeing reports that
there's
Spanish language right wing Talk Radio
in South Florida
and it's having a
it's having a political effect
I know there are a lot of
Exile Cubans who seem to go pretty right
wing in reaction to
Cuba and why they left Cuba
as well as Venezuela it sounds like
there are there's lots of Venezuelans
who think the same way as a Spanish
speaker do you have any insights onto
this phenomenon
so there's a few different things this
is a really good important and complex
issue and you know the the Latino
electorate in American elections is
increasingly important and we've got to
figure this out because otherwise it's
not good for the left so generally
speaking
um immigrants to the United States from
Latin America tend to vote for Democrats
except the ones that don't
Cubans do not tend to vote for Democrats
Cubans are very Republican and they are
Republican
um mostly as a reaction to they say well
Castro was bad and the opposite of
Castro is Republican so that's basically
that that that's boiling it down to why
that is very similar thing with
Venezuela now I as a leftist who is not
a communist and who does not like
authoritarian strongman regimes my view
is different my view is well good okay
you didn't like the regime in Cuba you
left you didn't like the regime in
Venezuela you left now you're in the U.S
don't go for right-wing authoritarians
that's not the solution the solution is
social democracy which is my view but to
get to your point
when I did my Spanish language show
around the 2020 election on the Estrella
Network
the amount of conspiratorial thinking
all of the same conspiracies that we see
on Facebook in English they were
spreading like wildfire within Spanish
language groups in comments in response
to the clips I was doing the emails Etc
so the best advice for the left would be
you need to understand that this is an
electorate that you need that we need
and you need to way more proactively be
going out there and preventing folks who
come to the U.S and just get in these
right-wing Latino Echo Chambers because
even if most of the voters tend to go to
the left
um radio right-wing radio uh uh
right-wing Spanish language radio in
Florida is influencing a lot of these
folks who are like well it's the one
thing in Spanish so I'm going to listen
to it and it's wacky far right stuff and
the left has to figure out a strategy on
it
yeah that's good I I didn't realize that
you had a Spanish language
um show in 2020 that's yeah we did like
13 weeks basically like leading up to
the election and through the
inauguration
ah very interesting yeah
you can even check out my Spanish
language interview with LA mayor Eric
Garcetti on my YouTube channel
oh unfortunately I would not be able to
understand it well it's subtitle don't
worry
oh wow yeah oh that's cool yeah
yeah as uh
as a final thing
um I think I remember you talking about
the election fraud that occurred now
this is actually real election fraud
here in Florida and that was when uh
some fake candidates were
were put up in the state legislature
yeah and the right term I mean calling
them fake is funny but it's they're so
they would be like straw candidates they
are candidates made to take away votes
from your opponent and organized by a
different candidate yeah and that's
against the law to do
yeah like I think you talked about it
before and you weren't sure what exactly
had happened in terms of prosecution but
it looks like in one of the races
the they actually prosecuted him for for
um I think some kind of campaign Finance
violation and there was a former
say legislature legislator as well yeah
and he pled guilty in the race that the
Republican won by 32 points not 32
points 32 votes 32 votes okay
yeah so he actually pled guilty and then
the article I just read said he was all
apologetic and stuff like that oh I'm
sure I'm sure well yeah I know and the
straw candidate thing we're going to be
watching it very closely in 2022. all
right my friend appreciate the call very
much
all right sure all right there we go
um why don't we talk to
um oh I don't know I mean maybe uh
let's try
Marcos from Florida Marcos you're on the
air
hello
can you hear me you sound like you're
underwater we can hear you but you sound
like you're underwater
I'm sorry okay
um I don't know if it's better now but
it is I just want to say yeah I'm a fan
and uh I enjoy your show I was gonna ask
you about Trump's uh talking about the
Deep State yeah and
he's like blaming the Deep state for
everything that's wrong
but it was during his presidency so does
that mean he was not in charge is he
saying he was just a puppet right
no you're making a very good point which
is I mean listen so first of all what
Marcos is referring to is that during an
interview with Mark Levin this week
Trump blamed the Deep state for trying
to remove him from Office through the
FBI investigation deep state is just
another Shadow government conspiracy
that someone else is really in control
sometimes it's the Jews could be Bill
Gates could be the bilderbergs the
Illuminati the trilateral commission
whatever
um it's it's fascinating for you to
frame it in these terms Marcos because
if indeed the Deep state
was in charge at the time it means Trump
really was not in charge and at the same
time if Trump was in charge then why is
it that he wasn't able to take control
of the deep State and who is in the Deep
State because it was his government of
course and so it's all completely
incoherent and you're absolutely right
to point it out
no man Marcos we're losing you you're
going underwater more so I'm going to
let you go it's quite a connection uh
but I do appreciate you
um calling in today and it was really
really great speaking with you that's
going to do it for calls today folks we
will take calls again and next Tuesday
we have the David packman show viewer
Town Hall at 6 PM eastern time during
which we will be wide opening the
Discord lines and anybody who wants to
can call in let's take a quick break and
we will keep going with the Friday show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's get into some of your emails for
the week if you want to send an email
and maybe have it featured in the weekly
email bag you can email info
davidpackman.com Please be aware I I
can't believe I still have to admit this
admonishment if you start emailing
multiple times a day and there are now
like 30 or 40 people doing it your
emails are being Auto filtered into the
trash we just can't have this stuffed
email box it's not what it's for we are
not you know some people are sending us
just 30 news stories a day it's not an
appropriate use of the email box you you
might as well stop we're not seeing your
emails but for other people uh info
davidpackman.com if you're going to
reasonably use that we love hearing from
you let's get right into this week's
email back bag a first email is from Jay
bear who says why do you avoid race and
IQ are you afraid of the truth we've
gotten emails like this before
Jay bear writes you seem quite scared
David of the truth the link between race
and IQ is as clear as day
Stefan molynukes and Lauren Southern
have discussed in length about this
before and they aren't racists Jews
actually have higher IQs than others and
you probably realize this but you can't
say it don't be so afraid of reporting
The Truth Listen to Charles Murray Dr
David Duke and Stefan molyneux
um every time I get one of these I
always have to do a two-part response
first of all why are you so obsessed
with this topic with all of the things
going on in the world why would someone
continually be fixated on this topic but
most importantly it's not a subject that
I've voted avoided we have a long form
video the truth about race and IQ go
watch it and that's all I have to say on
the matter now the problem is people see
the video
and then they say well but David I don't
agree with your conclusions you need to
do another video these folks won't be
happy until I just agree with them and
that's a very different uh request that
they're making we've talked about it
it's not an interesting topic to me
we've said everything we want to say
about it and that's it
Bill wrote in Kyle from South Florida
about uh Chris Cuomo and says in Chris
Cuomo's defense David I was listening to
your take yesterday on the situation
regarding Chris Cuomo's suspension from
CNN I agree with you for the most part
him using his connections to help his
brother during a scandal is totally
inappropriate and is absolutely a
violation of journalistic Integrity
however I did not find it necessary to
Warrant a suspension in Cuomo's defense
he is the most watched hour of CNN as in
and is an influential voice on the left
why should he be suspended when
journalists on right wing propaganda
networks resume business as usual making
wildly false claims and peddling
dangerous conspiracies conspiracy
theories as a progressive I'm getting
tired of holding ourselves to a certain
moral standard like journalistic
Integrity while the right threw that out
of the window a long time ago
I'm not saying we should ever stoop to
their level but I am saying we may want
to reevaluate who and what we should be
condemning people for Chris Cuomo
suspension is unnecessary not all it
since this email it actually became a
firing I disagree with this you know
this is like when uh when Keith olberman
uh violated policy by making some
political donations when he was working
at MSNBC and he was was he suspended and
then fired or just fired he was punished
for it a whole bunch of people said look
at Fox News the entire network is
politically biased people who are
participating in fundraisers for
candidates and doing all this stuff so
nothing should happen to Keith Olbermann
I I'd reject that once we say we don't
need to hold ourselves to sensible
standards because they aren't doing it
um I think in some sense we become as
bad as them now I've said before
there are cases where we just need to
play the game for example gerrymandering
the way that the Republican party has
gerrymandered manipulated congressional
districts to their advantage is
disgusting it shouldn't be allowed but
it is
and the left has no choice but to do the
same anytime they have the opportunity
until such time that we have a different
way of drawing districts but you're
going to just keep losing if you don't
do that uh but you work to change the
rules here what Chris Cuomo did is
completely inappropriate and the
punishment has to fit the actions not
well what does or what would Fox News do
so I think Kyle I appreciate the message
we just have a difference of opinion and
that's okay but I think that Chris
Cuomo's suspension uh was completely
appropriate
um next email called fake news you are
correct in fact that Trump didn't invent
the term fake news actually it was one
of Hitler's favorite terms of course he
said Logan press I have observed it on
many Trump supporters probably neo-nazis
I froze the first time I heard it in our
language in 2016 before the election I
believe I saw his ultimate intention
then apparently according to his first
wife he read Hitler it's called my new
order and that alone is a little
chilling so yeah our so-called Patriot
mag crowd somehow doesn't realize it's a
fascist term used by an evil man who
proved his evil 100 times over yeah I
mean listen you're not wrong even more
recently the term fake news within the
United States had a particular meaning
and it was like you know the The
National Enquirer Hillary Clinton giving
birth to an alien baby that's what we
meant by fake news Donald Trump has just
completely changed what it means into
any reporting critical of me or things
that I've done and said and obviously
that is a perversion of what fake news
uh has always has always meant
um
next is a tweet this was a tweet I got
uh I pointed out you know this this is
actually a bigger story
back when it was Hillary Clinton versus
Donald Trump in 2016. there were some
people on the left saying the Supreme
Court I don't care about the Supreme
Court Hillary and Trump are the same I
don't care I'm not voting or I'm writing
someone in or whatever Donald Trump got
three Supreme Court picks
um Neil Gorsuch Brett Kavanaugh and Amy
Coney Barrett and now as a result of
that
Roe v Wade may be undone in the United
States we're not going to know until
June and so I tweeted if Hillary had won
Roe v Wade wouldn't be on the chopping
walk now a few people wrote back and
said things like well she said she would
be open to compromise on Roe v Wade
listen that's something she said she
wasn't going to put in three
anti-abortion Supreme Court Justices
okay uh a user on Twitter wrote back and
said if Hillary had one we'd be in two
Wars and that is just such a boring
tired narrative it is the the the
killery stuff and we talked about this
Monday in the context of Joe Biden
dramatically scaling back the Drone war
after quite frankly Decades of pushing
this neocon warmongering stuff Trump
came in and said oh the Iraq War was bad
even though he said it was good when he
was interviewed by Howard Stern way back
when
um and said I'm not going to get us into
Wars and Hillary will and many trumpists
and Republicans fell for it hook line
and singer
um Hillary Clinton was not going to get
us into two Wars uh is it possible that
she would have engaged in some kind of
military conflicts airstrikes whatever
absolutely most presidents do Trump did
Obama did Bush Georgia yes but this
entire Hillary was bloodthirsty and
looking to start wars everywhere it
simply was not based in in any evidence
and by the way they've been saying the
same thing about Joe Biden we're not
closer to any War under Joe Biden if he
starts one we will talk about it believe
me but uh it's just a made up and
concocted narrative that a lot of people
fell for and if you actually ask them
what evidence do you have that Hillary
wanted to start two Wars see what
happens see what they say to you uh okay
next email this one comes to us is
actually a Facebook message you are a
piece of s Trump is the best president
in my lifetime 53 years Trump had
America independent on oil not true
unemployment at all time low uh yes
unemployment was low that that's
absolutely true
um and uh unemployment is also uh really
really low under Joe Biden they're not
giving Joe Biden any credit for that uh
future jog Outlook I guess they mean job
outlook highest ever and China economy
and shambles that's not true and of
course the tariffs on China were really
damaging to American companies and then
after getting an automatic response
saying that you know I can't respond to
these messages individually the same
person wrote back and said drop dead
liberal pukes this is what we're up
against guys
another Facebook message are you kidding
me Trump was the only president that put
our country first and the American
people first if you like living in
communist country move out
I am not a communist I'm not looking to
live in a communist country I'm not
looking for the United States to become
a communist country the continued
ignorance around what communism is
is plaguing us like a virus for lack of
a better term
Bernard wrote in Bernard writes uh David
I love your show
bonhoeffer's theory of stupidity on
YouTube channel Sprouts goes into what
is happening in America right now and
the danger of America losing democracy
hope this helps
um yeah I actually recently read a very
good article on bonhoeffer's theory of
stupidity
and the main point of that is stupidity
is a more dangerous enemy of the good
than evil and there's a number of
different ways in which you can make
that case I am very sympathetic to that
idea
and a part of what makes stupidity a
more dangerous enemy than evil
uh is that stupidity lends itself to
manipulation in a very particular way
that as we saw quite frankly under Trump
lends itself to getting people to
believe and support absurd things not
because they actually like them but
because they don't even understand them
they've been tricked they've been
bamboozled and I think uh there's a
really good if you search Google for
bonhoeffer's theory of stupidity there's
a medium article that explains it in
some pretty good detail that's worth
reading a John wrote in and says where
did Trump's oratory skills come from
David regardless of your or my feelings
on his character or policies you have to
admit that Trump is a skilled public
speaker although he has his malfunction
malfunctions United Sheikh and finding
the oranges to name a few he never AMS
or URS and can easily hold the crowd's
attention for an extended time my
question is where did these skills come
from I don't think he had any formal
training or would have a chance to
exercise them locked up in that Tower of
his what do you think yeah you know I
mean here's the thing John
in a sense you're right John uh Trump
was able early on to generate interest
his speeches were kind of wacky and
entertaining in a sense his press
briefings were certainly more lively
than those that Joe Biden has done but
at the same time A lot of times Trump's
rally crowds were completely bored
remember for a while when Trump would
come out with papers with polling on
them and he would start reading polls
and the crowd was totally checked out
recently he's done like hour and a half
hour 45 minute rallies a few months ago
and the crowd is totally tuned out so I
do agree that Trump has something that
makes him entertaining to some in a
superficial way but he also often loses
the crowd in a very immediate and kind
of jarring way so I I don't know
um even myself while as you say I don't
like the guy's policy positions or
anything else I did find myself
entertained by some of his events but
recently the endless sort of like Castro
type rallies where he's just going on
and on and on about nothing it's not
really entertaining and a lot of people
start walking out so I think it's a mix
uh and a trump fundamentally is an
Entertainer so it shouldn't shock us
that he has some tools to entertain on a
superficial level and obviously you and
I agree for the country it's not a good
thing at all
we have a great bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpakman.com you'll get
instant access to the bonus show as well
as our commercial free audio feeds and
commercial free video feeds for members
only sign up at joinpackman.com you can
use the coupon code better21 to get a
discount
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25 off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com davidpackman